[Musik]
ich bin ein cyborg weil ich einen
effizienteren mensch sein will nicht ein
besserer mensch aber ich glaube dass ich
mehr aus meinem eigenen leben rausholen
kann dass ich mehr aus fremden leben
rausholen kann indem ich denkanstöße
vorsorge also glaube ich dass ich in
effizientere menschen aber nicht besser
also besser müsste man werten und ich
sehe das gar nicht werden
[Musik]
für mich ist fortschritt der wichtigste
bestandteil vom leben ohne fortschritt
gibt es keine entwicklung
wenn wir jetzt nicht anfangen uns selbst
zu entwickeln den übermenschen schaffen
und die nächste stufe dann stagnieren
wir für alle zeiten und dass das
funktioniert nicht und das ist für mich
weder weder für die zukunft sinnvoll
noch für den menschen sinnvoll
ich trage implantat sehen wir die
funktionen haben
ich bin die mischung zwischen mensch und
maschine
[Musik]
es sieht düster aus vielleicht gerne
düster lebe also die leute nennen mich
grufti und ich glaube das bin ich im
klassischen sinne auch ich stehe
totenköpfe spucken kram pentagramme
einen ganzen tisch prinz zeug
ich mag den begriff die kitsch
[Musik]
angefangen habe ich mit achtzehn wir
sind im tierhandel gang und ich habe
gesagt jetzt setze ich mich mal so
einteilen wir haben uns für die kühe die
normalerweise in die ohren kommen haben
uns einen chip gesetzt habe ich mir in
die handfläche gespritzt und jetzt lebe
ich einfach los und gucken was ich damit
machen kann ich hab leider nicht viel
damit machen können weil das knowledge
gefehlt hat die community hat gefehlt
aber ich war neugierig war ich fand er
selbst wird ziemlich cool und gesagt
jetzt legen einfach los in meiner
rechten hand habe ich einen lauf welt
konzert präsentiert mal oder nicht nur
die narbe meiner linken hat da sieht man
den chat ist ein hifi konzert drin
dann habe ich noch einen ganz alten das
aus 17 jahre alt habe ich hier drin da
habe ich mit ihr als mehr ansprechen
lassen der ist leider schon tot und das
gleiche habe ich dann noch mal auch noch
den tod der chip was ich mache kann ich
kann mein telefon mit meinem job
entsperren
das muss ich die stelle finden zeigt ist
das telefon gesperrt
ich kann mir eine textdatei hinterlegen
als datensatz nur seine website ich toll
finde an so funktion ich kann man
facebook profil mind uhr zum einen liegt
in hinterlegen wenn ich das gern möchte
mein steam account für die paranoiden
kann es für ein bitcoin konto internet
ich habe mich für chips entschieden
obwohl es natürlich auch möglich ist mit
meinem gesicht mein iphone zu entsperren
oder wenn man fingerabdruck das heißt ja
nicht dass der fingerabdruck oder das
face unlock weniger praktisch sind im
grunde ist der chip und praktische ich
muss einen vorgang mehr machen aber ich
möchte mit den antrieb schaffen
ich möchte damit ich möchte durch konsum
interesse wecken das heißt umso mehr ich
konsumiere in sachen mit chips mit
upgrades mit jerry buss und was es da
alles gibt versuche ich mit den leuten
die das auch vertretenen markt zu
schaffen
das heißt wenn wir konsumieren und wird
irgendjemand immer ein interesse haben
damit geld zu verdienen
male body modification und meine siebte
mal implantaten effektiv keine funktion
es ist rein durch mein aussehen ändern
möchte er
[Musik]
ich habe mal kennengelernt als ich einen
vortrag gehalten habe und er hat sich
als zuschauer gemeldet
wir vertreten uns gegenseitig in der
öffentlichkeit also wir teilen sehr viel
in unserem spektrum unserer wahrnehmung
unserer realitätswahrnehmung und wir
haben den gleichen gedanken
ich wurde eingeladen über 20 - zu
sprechen
über das ibook leben weil ich mich das
selber bezeichnet und bisschen
aufklärung zu treiben den leuten zeigen
was wir tun und ein bisschen mit den
leuten erklären was wir dafür tun die
leute sind mutig hier sind bereit sich
eine andere rolle zu begeben sind bereit
anderen menschen zu akzeptieren und sind
auch bereits neue ideen anzuhören also
ich finde das sehr gut sagt wir haben
gestern sogar gesprochen du hast gesagt
du würdest jetzt auf dein leben dann
physisches leben verzichten und
digitaler form weiter zu leben
du würdest jetzt schon den schritt
machen wird es nicht bis ins alter
warten absolut hast du keine angst vor
der unendlichkeit
für mich ist nun endlich hat nicht so
ein problem weil wenn mein körper haben
der immer funktioniert er immer fähig
ist da ist verstehe ich den punkt nicht
warum die unendlichkeit ein problem sein
sollte weil ja möchte jetzt nicht
sterben warum sollte ich in pension
stärken wollen wenn ein geologischer
körper dann endlich zu einem ende kommt
dann ja dann legt doch die maschine
weiter aber durch selbst wisse dann
trotzdem weitergekommen
ja also für mich aus kopie dann geht das
genauso weiter ausführt und mein leben
weiter hat als die kopie aber die
entwicklung die danach starb wenn du
hast bin weiterhin ich also ich mache
eine digital ist eine digitale kopie vom
verstand vom gehirn an dem punkt das
heißt ich bin eins zu eins dasselbe an
dem punkt wo ich gespalten
das heißt ich verändere mich erst danach
endlich will science fiction blog ich
glaube mein top loading ist nicht es
keine fantasie aus der science fiction
ich glaube ich dass er zu für science
fiction geguckt haben
ich glaube dass uns science fiction den
mut gegeben hat wünsche zu äußern dass
ein geist und ein bewusstsein
digitalisiert wird ist tatsächlich
irgendwann möglich dass ein geist an
zwei stellen digital existieren kann als
kopie als clown man das dann immer
aussieht das wird auch passieren
bisher leben wir das eine andere
geschichte
dass man einen geist in einem anderen
körpers worten kann das ist das bodies
worten oder wirklich worten das wird
auch passieren wenn du dir vorstellst du
bist sterbenskrank du hast die
möglichkeit dein bewusstsein in einen
anderen körper zu stecken oder digital
weiter zu leben für alle zeiten
die leute werden das wollen
[Musik]
er schreibt
ich bin die schweiz gekommen weil in
basel eine cocktailbar manager gesucht
hat was mein spezialgebiet ist also ich
arbeite mit cocktails ich bin eigentlich
der klassische barkeeper arbeite
inzwischen aber eher in der
geschäftsführung aus ba-manager ich
kümmere mich um konzept ich kümmere mich
schon das angebot und eigentlich was
administrativ drumherum passiert ja
im beruf merkt man eigentlich nichts von
meinem privatleben es kann passieren
dass jemand meine arme sieht und das was
auffällt dass ich implantate trage
grundsätzlich trenne ich das ganz
bewusst und ich finde beruf hat es uns
zu suchen und das ist mein privates
pressure soll auch nicht ein beruf
reflektiert werden der mensch ist an
einem punkt angelangt tor stagniert wir
haben keine entwicklung mehr
ich glaube nicht dass ein mensch
glücklich ist wenn er einfach auf dem
stand bleibt wo er ist eine rein
geistige entwicklung reicht mir nicht
und es ist auch tatsächlich für die
zukunft nicht ausreichend es muss eine
körperliche und physische entwicklung
geben
das heißt ja nicht dass das eine das
andere ausschließen muss aber das eine
kann durch das andere folgen wenn wir
geistige entwicklung durchmachen durch
bewusstes leben bewusst dass
informationen konsumieren und so weiter
und so fort
entwickeln wir automatisch das bedürfnis
auch physische entwicklung zu haben das
ist ganz normal wenn du dir über deinen
körper so bewusst bist dann möchtest du
makel entfernen
du möchtest schwachstellen entfernen
[Musik]
meine schilddrüse ist nicht gesund und
für mich ist natürlich ein persönliches
interesse dass ich irgendwann die
schilddrüsenfunktion dieses ding
momentan noch trägt mit einer maschine
ersetzen kann ganz klar ich möchte nicht
darauf verzichten ich möchte es ersetzen
ich möchte nicht frage hier sein ich
möchte nicht auf körperfunktion
verzichten müssen wenn ich die
möglichkeit habe meine schilddrüse die
nicht richtig funktioniert durch eine
maschine zu ersetzen die piekfeinen
funktioniert solange sie anständig
behandelt dass das absolut größte also
ich würde wahrscheinlich dass maschinen
mehr vertrauen aus meiner eigenen
angegriffene schiff ist
[Musik]
menschen die mir nahestehen wir sind das
gewohnt ist sein dass die spinne mal
wieder der macht es mal wieder in andere
quatschen guck mal wieder auf eine
spinnerei und tut sich das an
also man wird viel belächelt aber auf
eine respektvolle dass man im feld
es gibt tatsächlich kritiker die das
sehr verurteilen das gibt es natürlich
auch um das geht bis zu beschimpfungen
hin
das gehört dazu aber ich wurde noch nie
irgendwie angegriffen im sinne von so
deformiert beleidigt oder so dass ich
sagen dass ich muss das verstecken oder
so das auf keinen fall
[Musik]
so allofs
sind dann besser
ein bisschen größer
es wird lustig ich lasse mir ein xp chip
implantat setzen das tolle an dem chip
ist der kann man den körper wärme an der
stelle wo ist mir implantieren
analysieren und ich kann es auswerten
geräten ablesen könnte man aber ich
finde das 40 es kann einfach sein das
ist ein muskel erwischt ein bisschen ist
nicht so schlimm wie es klingt ich habe
ja die muskulären es tut weh aber es ist
nicht so tragisch aber ich will nicht
genug nahrung geht ja schon einige chips
gesetzt
die andere schon einige tipps der salbe
mittlerweile und ich brachte fahrers
oder mit der schaufel steril und sagt
eigentlich kein problem darstellen
der chip ist steril in der nadel drin
deswegen sieht man auch nicht wenn man
es implantiert und wird dann durch die
kanüle in die haut reingedrückt
gehe ich einfach genau das was da über
stört ja ich glaube da wird weh tun
haben sagt der cd aber schuldig
alles alles cool mit die pflaster tiptop
danke auch für tot
[Musik]
ich möchte eigentlich mal eine komplette
identität auf meinen chip haben das
fängt bei einem schlüssel an dass ich
meine tür öffnen darf also meine
berechtigung meine idee karte mal eine
bewilligung am besten auch und mein geld
das möchte ich alles haben ich möchte
mich von diesem zurückgefragt mike ist
schon dabei der kann seine tür schon
öffnen
er kratzt aber auch mit den fingern
wasser bezahlen darf wir warten
eigentlich nur darauf dass uns das
jemand gestattet musik war für mich
immer absolut wichtig also in jeglicher
hinsicht
mein ziel ist es tatsächlich diese ganz
knöpfe die ich hier habe überall
verteilt habe
das sind ja nichts anderes als niedriger
das heißt hinter jedem knopf und hinter
jeder bewegung ist ein kleines signal
das wird an meinem computer geschickt
der computer macht das was ich hier
drücke ich möchte das hier drauf
übertragen das ist ein kleines eeg gerät
damit kann ich moment in kleinen roboter
steuern
das ist ein kleiner hubschrauber sieht
aus wie eine droge mit denen kann ich
ungefähr drei bis vier befehle ausführen
ich möchte aber jeden befehl den ich
hier habe überall möchte ich mir über
einen übertragungs gerät und eine eg
gerät was über hirnströme funktioniert
komplett stoll trigger eigentlich
befehle in dem ich daran denke dass war
die konzentration das sind die das sind
die hirnwellen die von diesem gerät
erfasst werden und umso besser die
natürlich sind sie mir auch schläge habe
ich hier oben
dh habe ich mich quartier obendrauf
konzentrierten geht meine meditation
hoch wenn ich wirklich überlegen muss
was ich sagen will zum beispiel also das
kann ich gerade mal probieren habt ihr
wieder hochgeht
es ist jetzt hoch ich fange ich an zu
konzentrieren und sie wird hoch also
wenn ich natürlich eine eg hat mit 32
ablesen punkten
anstatt nun an dann kann ich natürlich
deutlich mehr effizienz herausholen
utopische vorstellung dass ich das
jemals schaffen sollte könnte ich mich
voll auf meinen stuhl setzen und alle
steuern ohne einen finger krumm zu
machen
[Musik]
ich gehe davon aus dass wir mit der
technik verschmelzen und ich gehe davon
aus dass es unabdingbar ist ich gehe
davon aus dass es in der gewissen zeit
tatsächlich so normal ist dass man sich
eher wundert dass es nicht früher
passiert ist der chip funktioniert
tadellos die schwellung ist weg das
grundwasser ist weg und er macht seinen
dienst einwandfrei ich bekomme konstante
körpertemperatur wärme von der stelle
und ich bin mehr als zufrieden
er hat wunderbar funktioniert ich möchte
meinen körper jederzeit überwachen
können also meine motivation ist die
medizin
ich möchte jederzeit auf meinem ipad
oder warteräume ich dann benutze alles
sehen was in meinem körper vorgeht und
blutzucker bis zum einer
muskelentzündung bis zu meiner
zahnfleisch rückbildung bis zu meinem
haarwuchs alles ich möchte jeden punkt
nachvollziehen können und somit aus
steuern können
möchtest du den berg besiegen ob den tod
besiegen möchte wenn ich mutig bin ja
ganz ehrlich wenn ich die möglichkeit
hätte ein echtes leben in der
unsterblichkeit zu verbringen und man
tod selber bestimmen zu können das wäre
wahrscheinlich das größte was ich was
ich erreichen könnte und ich möchte ist
ich könnte tatsächlich mein potenzial
völlig ausschöpfen weil ich habe dieses
zeitfenster nicht mehr
das ist der kernpunkt wo wir hinwollen
[Musik]
[Applaus]